for three years bro
of probation
well actually four years of probation i
wasn't able to smoke weed and that's my
thing i smoke well like i'm a [ __ ]
weed head you know so i had to you know
compromise i was smoking spice oh that's
just dangerous bro i would pass the
blunt to people and they would pass out
right next to me that's that i grabbed
my blunt bag and keep smoking you were
smoking spice like how often
30 blunts a day bro of spice spice
30 blunts a day people that were around
me my brother he'll tell you did you
have any episodes on that [ __ ] i did but
not to where it freaked me out
completely because i already seen what
it was doing to everybody else so when
they'll hit me in that little weird
state i just kind of ride it out and
just sit there and wait and be like
what is that weird state feel like
because i think with we think of spice
it's like an adrenaline when we think of
the guy in miami who [ __ ] was wilding
out and he bites somebody eating
[ __ ]
but like what like what's like the
craziest spice like what is that what is
that this is just a crazy adrenaline
that i got while i was you know smoking
um
i've been with some of my homies and
we're smoking and my homies get a whole
picture in their head like they're about
to kill us take me home type [ __ ] and
i'm like bro we good we're at the gas
station we're just going to get gas
don't trip
and i'm tripping i'm tripping type [ __ ]
so i know it affected different people
majority of the people that it did
affect while i was with them their first
instinct like their first thing that
came to mind was i'm gonna die
they would always grab their head and oh
my god i'm about to die and i'm like bro
you're not just chill you know what i
mean you never felt that way mm-hmm i
got to where i mean you were smoking 30
a day man so i i built a hell of a i'm
glad you're still here but you know
thank god man
everywhere in neighborhoods that i'm not
supposed to be in standing in line
trying to buy spice to where the dudes
will come in and be like you from
florence and i'm like yeah
you know you're not supposed to be like
yeah i'm just gonna get something from
the store real quick i'm good like so
you were like seeking out spice
everywhere no matter where you had to go
type [ __ ] and it was funny because it
started becoming illegal so you go to
like one little smoke shop and they'd
have it on the wall like oh we don't got
it no more but you could go two blocks
to the right make 11 words right there
and then you're like i'm on my way like
now i know people who got locked up uh a
smoke shop owner in arizona got locked
up because he was a
i think he was like one of the
distributors of that [ __ ] a lot of
people i know who are like
in that industry got got hit with some
serious charges and that dude had to go
to jail for a few years over spice bro
i've seen people just take a hit and
just start having a seizure right next
to me where i'm like
what the hell yeah it kind of reminds me
of like uh i guess in the 90s when
people were doing angel dust right right
and it's funny that it lights basically
like the same like it flames up it's
something that whatever chemicals it was
that they were putting in there they're
not good for people yeah no [ __ ] and on
the back on the bag and the packaging it
says not for human consumption that's
what a lot of people would get mad at me
about they're like you reading that what
are you still doing you know
but i'm like i can't smoke weed this is
the closest i get to weak because nine
out of ten times that i smoke that blunt
it makes me feel like i'm hot like i
smoked a blow on a weed wow the spice
that's [ __ ] crazy and then they're
not pissed testing you for spice no
don't come out come out on your chest so
after all that was done you know i got
off probation i went straight back to
weed immediately cut the other [ __ ]
away and you know did you were you ever
involved in any other drugs like did you
ever have any any errors where you were
[ __ ] with anything when i was younger
you know what i'm saying i tried stuff i
tried smoking primos i tried all the
little
all the little [ __ ] you know what i
mean but it just nothing never stuck
with me nothing ever
caught my my attention like that and i
just you know that's not me i know some
people like will go to go to prison and
like because of the time or because of
boredom or whenever they pick up like
heroin
it happens it happens you know i i
myself
chose not to i'm the type of person that
if i like something i like it and i'll
keep doing it right so i don't want to
even test myself like that you know so
i'm happy that i like weed because i'm
gonna keep doing that